se puede mirar la vida y una Ciudad
Mucha gente creo que no lo creo en
contrato durante mi vida muchos
intendente spa Verna puertas que siempre a
Fierman bueno
miss you Dada's muy grande nos possible
miss you dad no tenemos los recursos yo
les digo des quiero compartir
reso despues de casi Cuarenta nos trabajando
en las ciudades creo que una ciudad y el
mejor r su calidad de vida significativa
Amenti a menos de três anos si se puede
pero es necesario oro voluntad
politica Solidaridad astrati heya pero mas
importante encontrar una Buena ecuación
de cuerpo  bueno quiero
empezar un personaje algunas personas y
di only broken a scree be a save in
Tejanos atras tratando de enseñar la
ciudad a los ninos adolescentes a gente
a pro la cidades en mejor ejemplo a
calidad de vida paramus la tortuga por
que la tortuga responsabilidad es  vivir r trabajar SI
movimento juntos al mismo tiempo el Casco
a Tortuga tiene el un des n o di una
tesitura Urbana
que puede Oh Corrine see ku  rta Romo's
del caso de la Tortuga Vivier a key
trabajar IE LOC IE
la tortue has Eva Amurri r es Atum NT lo
que estamos haciendo con nuestras cidades
VV r ik e trabajar ghettos de gente muy
rica ghettos de gente muy pobre estamos
Matan Doh a la  ciudad y además la ciudad
es un organic MO quanto messy mess ha
quanto messy mezcla ingresos da days fun
Sione's mess amana
las you dad say kedah ayer otro
personaje de sel Ebro s ato el Otomo
vida es un tipo muy gusta que viene ahí
está lleno hair  a salir y baby mucho y
hace mucho y es muy gusta por que solo
transporta una dos o tres personas que
digo ultima mean a key el coche es como
nuestra su Agri meccanica tenemos que
turb whenas relaciones kono esta su
Agra's pero no podemos dejar que es
commanding las vidas en otras palabras
se la única mujer de tu vida es su su
agra - tienes UN problema
bueno para me el tipo mess
solidary o es el bond o neo a ser bosom
ego transporta Tracey entus personas las
normas sua cos d  is endo siento say tenta
su echoes tres en toes brazilians
Karasu dad
ten young days no.16 Arceus radial
Curitiba Rio Oaxaca San Francisco na
California e
cidade es una estructura de vida a
trabajo juntos toda vez que se paramos
vida de trabajo ocurra el desastre ESO  no
es solamente en la ciudad es un estado
en un país tratar de la economía sin las
personas SS desastre a kiss la
estructura leve de trabajo de curitiba
Oh a pasar muy rapido mente es una
subida trabajo de transporte todos
juntos yaki I'm as dense  adonde a man's
oferta
de transporte público aquí los Bulls en
gorillas conceive oh yeah loco no see a
eye crease problemas que son muy
importantes en toda la ciudad del mundo
see education see salud
see La Segura Segura dad atencional
Nino para tres puntos y MP essential a
fundamentals no solamente para Westra
cidades como para toda la humanidad
un problema es la mobile Adad el otro es
la sostenible dad y el Tercero la socio
diversidad poor tom Oh Belin  da se pone
Oh sensei puede hacer la gente es para
as veces un sistema es muy caro
e se espera mucho y nosotros empezar
Mo's yo Naaman era muy sensi de un bus
kur endo
n carrera exclusivo empezamos convencido
cinco mil pasajeros
por dia hoy el sistema transport
dose me Leona's atrás en dos mil
pasajeros aldea en Seaguar a new el paso
hairs del metro San Paolo II mosque el
metro de Rio junto con el tren de
Saborio pero neck a consist a es un
pequeño tuvo que transforma elbows a new
metro que de Alba  slam ESMA la misma
performance a you Metro a same Barca say
perrantes same Barca al mismo Nevada nos
espera Mizuki un minuto por el bus ya
see it s in vidrio a se como Opera in
viscid odd pocos metros en el mundo en
la posibilidad our mobile Adad  a gente
portada hora de deficiencia pero esto y
una Hempel de hoy on Cayo accredit el
futurist on la superficie
yo creo que hoy está en
use our tolosa stemis y CI un metro cassia
intelligente see IM bullski center gente
on  tax intel frente una bicicleta
intelligente un coche intel gente y el
segredo es la mobile Adad esta en llamas
disputado el mismo espacio
oh say ser complement our low E a kilos
françaises
Transvaal Manos la bicicleta en un
transporte público que aqui es el coche
men or po  che del mundo dispelled abou
Hondo hora estamos en el cuarto
prototipo oh no soy un de senador de
coaches pero el concepto de un coche que
no - no es bueno es un coche de kado
docking car
dock dock is who cuarto Delta my Adele
smart
yo intro  dentro del gotcha s doc doc doc
Oddo yaki is de cómo funciona
dhak dhak dhak dhak dhak dhak ahora a
casa es el sistema estamos hablando para
la olimpiadas en rio e aquí como se hace
la Integration del bus con el metro de
sistema es el mismo sólo  el vehículos
diferentes pero puede imaginar in vitro
con el e d esto en el pasaje
de rio de janeiro bueno el otra cosa es
posible tener una Ciudad sin pedophilia
si es posible aqui es un estudio kiss
emos para  el futuro de San Paolo
own a tomamos eltra Soloff Erica Reed
di Bahamas una promenade
Arriba delt Rosado para que si
connecting total hasta los tipos de
ingresos a la gente el área es
equivalente a dos veces a Central Park in
New York a la gente SE puede  connector e
y de bicicleta caminar por toda la
ciudad y toda la gente terry acceso a
transporte público porque el tren de su
bug lo está bajo Yaqui safe where
connector todo
vivianne de buen que es una Ciudad
sostenible a participante a muchas
reuniones Mucha gente piensa en la
sociedad es nuevos materiales muy
importante es nuevas
warmest Denorfia muy importante es llegamos reciclaje s
edificios Verdes todo es muy importante
pero a que pensar el más importante es
que se tent a Cinco por ciento LOC
Misiones de carbono estancia Regina en
la ciudad A's Oh c'  est si en la ciudad
que podemos ser más eficaz OHS como
OT resentir o menos el coche say / ando la
basura y VV ma cental trabajo Racine
complete ahmo's u  na película que trata
de enseñar a los ninos
como torn are Sociedad mesotainable a
aquí como se cambio de Maio Metro
cuadrado para cincuenta dos Metro squad
ad for a baton in Curitiba y como si
transform o Las Canteras NC escogió la
universidad liberal may ambiente jardin
botanico a corona Cantera say transform
o en t Otto en dos meses que se rapido
yay varias personas para ser rapido una
pareja tar Nostra propia burocracy ax
dos una vez la decision
pen Simoes esto
no es posible es Mediano
casados a possible ikm pasar por que in / es
mpezar podemos describir un trata
o de co
unidad movimiento los brazos al mismo
tiempo para momento que tu veux Ghoul
a's en el agua o era tan fácil yamir
el cuarto con el joven  emu Hoeven
via tratado sobre sexo y despues me
cuenta que Rizzo anisia no Anat and
Avicii
aqui Canteras que fueron transformed
Addas aqui como si de change la basura
e ins  El equipo evalúa Campanas comenzando por
los niños es importante lauder Anton
dice mezda ensign ah Moses Mussina's a
los ninos ensign Aaron a sus Padres e I
sa tenta por ciento de la gente in
Curitiba say para la basura en su casa y
bueno identidad ecomo SE transforma como
si do muy rapido men test a cambio cree
and OC choose k respecting a nuestra
identi de a park a ucraniano o el parque
plaque o el parque hopin s el parque a
lemon a inmediata Ament a después Ronnie
on sovietic a CDS / co e denim como
tenemos gente de as a kiss tank as a
kiss on to be kissed on booze
becky stunts
tuvimos que para el pro el programa
bueno yo
Despero decir que es importante entender
kiss nasa da SE puede cambiar inmediatamente
Ament a eso es que yo Shamu a composer
ah
osya decir poesía rumah nueva energía
economista acciones vocalista equiparando de
una nueva Energia la ciudad yaki sm+ de
a computer as magnifique
simple enman or parque de nova or key
tres important a DOS SMS bonito a El
Museo de Oscar Niemeyer in Curitiba aquí
estamos haciendo el pabellón de la bossa
nova en Rio a aquí el museo de la
movilidad El Museo de la sustentabilidad'
Yaqui una computer a capo pussy a Mo's
para bono say La Bombonera e komova
sear a era Mochrie el  presidente despues
asumir EO la intendente no Evo
Presidente no key no keys hacer pero
para mí sigue siendo la bombonera san
paulo y las calles portátil is como tre
vida y como planner el agua mirador bono
Deborah Celia Oh
e trailer vida Encinos estan decadent
ace yaki un  parque own de un de manera
muy sencilla convoke AZ bamboos say crea
una pasa decembre no a que gastar mucho
recurso
haciendo en todo del mundo
como se bar murio en la republica
dominicana
bueno para aqui como occup are una Isla
a mess at ray mexico y como recuperar
el / Phil do Morro para aqui la ca
lle portátil yes estamos Desiree ando y IE
esta
e el hombre Tortuga yo yo yo Auriga la
casa en en la spada well sir Verdes way
invitar a cantar comigo a tengo de la
sustentable'
bandoneon bandoneon bandoneon bandoneon
who's de menos tepache sigue siempre
bandoneon bandoneon bandoneon  bandoneon
separe ooh basura into propria beat
asean bandoneon bandoneon Viva cerca del
trabajo
seiga siempre se yong-pan Dhoni on si se
puede Macanudo gracias